hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast proteome centric
precision medicine embracing
pathological diversity a black rock I am
Brenda hmmm and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
beckman coulter life sciences beckman
coulter life sciences is dedicated to
improving the health of people around
the world the company's global
leadership and world-class service and
support delivers sophisticated
instrument systems reagents and services
life science researchers and academic
and commercial laboratories enabling new
discoveries biology based research and
development for more information please
visit www older calm we have a few
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit your
questions by typing in in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. jennifer
van Eyck PhD is a professor of medicine
at cedars-sinai medical center director
of the basic science research in the
barbra streisand women's health center
and director of the new advanced
clinical biosystems institute where she
recently moved from johns hopkins
university the institute mandate is to
facilitate application proteomics
through medicine and enhanced
translation of new therapies and
biomarkers to clinical use through the
application of
innovative technologies her research
laboratory suggests studies the
underlying molecular mechanism of heart
and vascular disease using a large
number of proteomic methodologies
focusing on the site specific
identification and quantification
disease induced post translational
modification the underlying concept
competitive post translational
modifications that act as molecular
switches that sense and respond to
dynamic changes within the cell widely
regarded as an international leader in
the field of proteomics van Eyck is best
known for developing a number of lab
tests to determine the presence of
certain proteins or amino acids in
patients blood which could indicate
whether or not they have experienced a
heart attack or has heart disease she
earned her bachelor of science degree
and biology and chemistry at the
University of Waterloo Canada and her
doctorate in biochemistry at the
university of alberta edmonton during
her directorship of the Johns Hopkins
Heart Lung and Blood Institute
proteomics Center a National Heart Lung
and Blood Institute the johns hopkins
university school of medicine then i
also served as director david proteomics
group and as professor of medicine in
the division of cardiology she has over
210 peer-reviewed man scripts reviews
book chapters and has co-edited two
books I will now turn it over to
Jennifer for her presentation thank you
very much and welcome everyone I'm
delighted that you've all joined today
so over the next 45 minutes we're going
to discuss hopefully with questions
coming from you really how we can use
proteomics to address this emerging
field of precision medicine it actually
isn't an emerging field but rather
precision medicine has been the focus of
many research laboratories and many
clinical laboratories for a long time
trying to be able to get to really this
concept of being able to get the
medicine directly to the right disease
so that's precision therapy when we're
trying to understand the pathways of
disease and being able to develop drugs
that will target specific
parts of that pathway so precision
therapy the other side of course of
personalized medicine is really the
ability to diagnose or prognosis the an
individual's disease based on in our lab
the proteome so to do this the concepts
behind that is that we want to be able
to quantify an individual's proteome and
that comes from the premise that the
proteome that we would be measuring at
this moment reflects their past meaning
whether or not the epigenetics whether
or not they have been under more Redux
conditions will be reflected in the
proteome so that's a presence and how
the present proteome is will of course
dictate how you will respond in the
future so how your disease will progress
and also of course how you would react
to a certain therapy so by being able to
quantify explicitly the proteome we
should be able to understand their past
and the impact of the past on how they
will respond to the drug therapy and
being able to produce both the drugs
that will be right on target for those
particular nuances as well as being able
to diagnose where an individual is in
the disease progression becomes the
really the centerfold of personalized
medicine so to do this we believe that
we have to understand how the different
omics interact and that's just not a
metabolomics and genomics and proteomics
but all the perturbations within
proteomics self those different post
translation modifications that can
influence how different proteins
interact with each other so when you
think this way one of the underlying
principles that you have to be able to
do is to produce a technical pipeline
that allows you to be accurately I could
in your measurement across all the
different post translation modifications
that with a subset and have an ability
to have it scalable so being able to do
tens ten examples to be up to thousands
of samples in the same accuracy of the
quantification so when we think again
about precision medicine and having an
ability to precisely measure these
proteins the idea behind it is to be
able to both intervene at to obtain
better clinical decisions for individual
patients so
of course that gets down to being able
to get the right disease mechanism
getting the right drugs and being able
to select the patient based on
biomarkers but there's another side to
Dalton not discussed certainly at the
proteomics level and that's the ability
to improve public health and to do that
we have to start to decide and talk
about things like point of care devices
and screening programs and policies that
will allow us to reach out into the
unmet populations that require better
health care that are currently not being
addressed and so today we'll be talking
a lot about being able to find
mechanisms to be I have better clinical
decisions in the hospital setting but
also at the very end I'm going to talk
about how there's new technology being
an invented and being applied that
allows us to reach out into the
population so this is a narrative
process as we start to move both
biomarkers and understanding of
mechanisms to technologies allow us to
increase our throughput and always the
quality of the data matters and having
precise measurements of data is really
what we're about it better in our
research lab so you might ask well why
proteins and certainly proteins are not
the only place to get good biomarkers
and it's certainly very reasonable to
mix quantitation around proteins with
genomics and metabolomics and other
omics fields but one of the reasons that
we particularly like proteins is that
you're able to really monitor as I
mentioned earlier the past of a person
the remediate proteome as well as what
we could predict to be their future
response and that's because proteins
have this incredible diversity based on
both their isoforms or splice variants
as well as post translation
modifications just which exponentially
increase the biological diversity of
what one protein can do so measuring the
protein itself is important but being
able to quantify whether or not you have
a specific splice variant or whether or
not you have multiple post translational
modification really is where we need to
be in our field and protein at post
translation modifications are remarkable
because a single protein can have a one
amino acid residue that's modified by
more than
post-translational modification the
license a great example of that is
assisting you can have one amino acid
that has competitive post translation
modifications competing for it there are
hundreds of post translation
modifications and many of them which we
do not have good tools to be able to
quantify let alone identify and what's
really remarkable is that post
translation modifications can be dynamic
and they can be reversible and also
irreversible in the one I'll be focusing
on today is an irreversible post
translational modification it's called
sachula nation into deamidation of
arginine when it's part of a protein and
the delimitation of arginine is
irreversible and it is only through the
turnover of a protein that you're able
to regenerate the unmodified form at
least that's what we believe today so we
propose that if we're able to quantify
proteins and these disease to induce
modifications and the induction of new
isoforms perhaps we'll be able to be
more specific and be able to get those
refinement that we is required to be
able to get our drugs on target and to
monitor what's happening in the cell in
response to a drug therapy as well be
able to differentiate individuals and
how they'll respond to certain therapies
and how their progress in the future so
again the reason to be doing proteins
that they are really central to the
whole transcription translation and down
through metabolomics and lipidomics and
due to the modifications of subtleties
of what's happening in the cell should
be amplified so today I'm going to talk
about really three things why why we
think the individuals prototype the
protein to dictate the phenotype it's
going to be important and we're going to
focus in on our a rheumatoid arthritis
and heart disease and some potential
ways that we're thinking about new
therapies and new Diagnostics to monitor
this how can do scalable workflows and
the lot will be concentrated on this
really about automation of sample
preparation and as a development and
finally what is coming down next and
being able to really capture the
prototyping in a continuous
patient-centric healthcare screening i'm
trying again to move this out into
the larger population to reduce
healthcare barriers so let's start with
why so as I said the prototype is a word
that's supposed to bring to mind both
the concept of the proteome and its
impact really on the phenotype so again
we're starting with heart disease it is
the number one killer in the world right
now there is every one point 14 minutes
someone is diagnosed with heart failure
in the US or in Europe and there is
about a forty percent survival rate
after one years of diagnosis so we do
not really have early diagnostic markers
are indicated for heart failure women it
is a number call it one cause of death
and women and more women will die of
heart disease and males and of
interesting with autoimmunity which is
of course enriched in women's things
like RA and lupus you have an increased
odd ratio of getting heart failure so
there's something about autoimmunity
that is driving an increased risk of
having hard palate and of course that is
in of females enriched population
because autoimmune diseases such as are
as i mentioned happens more in women so
ra if you have RA you are at more risk
of developing heart failure and also
with stroke there's a higher preference
of office grosses and higher mortality
rates one of the interesting aspects of
RA is that they produce Auto antibodies
and auto antibodies can be induced by
protein modifications so being able to
your body to recognize self to recognize
a protein that should be there will not
simulate the autoimmune response however
if you have a non self recognized
protein to protein that's been modified
in such Allah nation this post
translational modification I mentioned
earlier it's a provocation that can
induce or has a higher propensity of
inducing an antibody response and
certainly citral a nation of proteins
with rail recognizing has been
recognized in the field of our way at
heightening of the Ottoman response and
being at least one of the modifications
that can drive other antibody response
central a nation is induced by an end
family called pad pepto arginine dima
disease and what it does essentially is
removed the nitrogen group from the side
chain of arginine and essentially makes
it go from a positive charge to neutral
excuse me on the left-hand side what
you'll see is a rahman meyer curve where
you can see the incident and survival
probability of women and men who have RA
of course is increased so you're more
likely to not survive if you have RA so
we're going to look at citral ination
the post translational modification that
is actually quite challenging in
proteomics to assess and quantify and we
have when we're talking about proteomics
a series of different methodologies one
can use for protein quantification and
I've listed a few here so in the field
of mass spectrometry we can use shotgun
who discover you traditional modes which
you know you're able to really quantify
thousands of proteins based on their
peptides and we do digest proteins into
peptides for mass spectrometry so we can
get increased accuracy of mass there is
other methodologies being developed
where we just look at protein intact
mass and but that's still developing and
I will not talk about that today on the
far right side we have targeted
methodology see some methodologies that
allows to very specifically monitor one
or more proteins but the numbers are
much smaller here maybe a hundred
proteins Eliza's are the most common
methodologies or things like western
blots where we're being able to quantify
and target specific proteins on the mass
spectrometry side we do the same thing
are using a technology called multiple
reaction monitoring or selective
reaction monitoring we're essentially
exclude all the peptides except the ones
that we want to measure and those
particular peptides we want to measure
are those which are unique to specific
proteins retargeting so essentially in
this methodology we exclude all the
peptides focusing on those specific
peptides which are prototypic and
representative the protein or the
peptide that has our potential post
translation modifications on it that's
the exact opposite to discovery
methodologies where we're trying to
really capture every single peptide to
our best ability and as I mentioned
shotgun discovery has been around for
over two
years and it's been very successful most
recently there's been a move towards a
slightly different combination approach
which is again both discovery but brings
in some of the aspects of targeted and
this is called data independent
acquisition and if you're using the
triple toss the trademark would be swap
in this way what we do is we pre build a
library of all potential peptides that
we would want to track but we don't
necessarily want every single peptide as
we do in discovery but we selectively
set of peptides which are representative
of those proteins are in our library so
in that way it's very similar to
targeted we pre select the peptides that
we want to really focus in on but
instead of just doing a hundred we're
going to be doing thousands and then we
pre build this library and then when
we're running our data independent
samples are our samples on using data
independent acquisition we're able to
map those back over to our library and
more efficiently see and quantify the
protein consept represented by those
peptides that we've targeted already but
again many many proteins so if we look
at this schematically this is a protein
and as we said we digested often with
trypsin making peptides that have lysine
at the n-terminus sorry at the
c-terminus or an arginine c-terminus and
that peptide in discovery mode we're
looking at all of those peptides at the
bottom each one of those blue triangles
is supposed to represent peptide that's
in our sample and as they could inject
it into the mass spectrometry over time
we detect them and the one that we're
interested is in red and it's coming out
and being alluded into the mass
spectrometry at specific time in mrm
assays essentially we exclude all those
blue peptides and focus in only on the
red one and were able to detect that
peptide and the way that we know that
it's at specific peptide is we give it
additional energy in ms to the to break
it down to smaller smaller peptides
which are representative Lee amino acid
sequence and these are called
transitions they are smaller peptides of
the existing parent peptide and that's
represented on the far right where we
can see the blue peak area that's your
parent and all the breakdown peptides Co
eluding great underneath it and
essentially when we want to quantify a
peptide we would quantify the peak area
underneath
that blue peak but we know that it's
right peak because of all these smaller
peptides which are essentially again
telling us the amino acid sequence of
that particular peptide so if we are now
monitoring more and more peptides of
course we want to not just quantitate on
one peptide but many peptides within our
protein they will elude at different
times in our our during discovery mode
and then Mr mo we know exactly when
they're going to come out and we
schedule them and essentially pick them
up and then we quantify again on the
different peak areas of each peptide
representing our proteins and you can
see how this is easy if we only
necessarily looking at one or two
proteins but when we want to live to
quantify hundreds of proteins or
thousands of proteins this becomes more
and more complicated so when we talk
about such relation you should be
thinking well why don't we just quantify
those particular peptides that have the
situation on the Argentine's been
modified to sit relation well the
challenges in mass spectrometry is that
situation is still a very low abundant
and has very low stoichiometry at the
peptide level so it's going to be very
low in our sample we have no direct
enrichment strategies right now so it's
not like we can go pull out those
peptides which are such unrelated the
switch on the nation itself is only a
one dalton mass shift and if we have
multiple charges on our peptides of
course we're measuring em over Z so
we're going to have even smaller change
there are other post translation
modifications that have the exact same
mass so it's going to be important to
take that arginine to citrulline change
in our peptide to an olympic identify it
and there's other parts of mass
spectrometry that makes it more
challenging so what we did with the
development of swath is to be able to
think if we were able to enrich our
protein library with such eliminated
peptides maybe that would help us see
those situated cap tides when we moved
forward to large-scale monitoring of
this protein modification in complex
samples so what we did is we would we
take our protein mixture let's say is a
heart or a knight order we precip
chillin ate it so we maximally situated
by adding the enzyme that induces
digested in this case we use lycée
because we're not changing arginine and
we don't want to use trips in which can
leave after that we want King cleavages
that we use life see we digest it we
make a peptide mixture that's now
heavily enriched of all possible such
eliminated residues we now include this
into our protein library now we actually
do a few more things we noticed while we
were doing this that when you have a
situated peptide it will change its
retention time on an LC by up two or
more than five minutes so we have
created an algorithm that allows you to
help with further characterization of
the characteristics that are unique to
assassinated peptide to unambiguously
identify and confirm that you have a sit
related peptide and when we did that if
we were for example to take our heart
and pre citral innate it make a digest
with lysine make our peptide library and
then run hard samples from human heart
in DIA mode and then look at those and
compare them back to our library add in
those other additional characteristics
to ensure that we really unambiguously
identify the central in a peptide we can
drastically enrich our competency and
the number of peptides that we are able
to identify so what you see in the bar
graph is if we were just to take a
sample and run it under shotgun we would
manually have to go through every single
one of our spectra that's being called
to be citral inated because of these
other issues and so you might have a
thousand and you will end up with being
able to identify about nine when we made
the library we were actually able to
enrich about 483 additional peptides
that are situated in the heart and we
put those into the library so that's a
maximum number we should be able to
identify and when we use our new
pipeline where we're essentially running
the DIA and then putting it through our
algorithms we're able to identify and
quantify 304 so this is a huge ability
now using dia methodology and this new
algorithm to be able to confidently
identify such an innate peptides so when
you do that in heart and we did it
against both healthy human heart and
heart that had with came was obtained
from individuals who have do two
different types of heart failure
ischemic and dilated heart failure
and ask the question are there situated
sites our proteins which are
differentially modified when you have
heart failure so of those 340 related
sites that we found in human heart 145
of them I would different Ross sorry 52
of them were differentiated so 52 of the
sites were different between control and
the two forms of heart failure and what
you see in the network analysis are the
types of proteins which are enriched in
citral a nation that were changed in
heart failure and you can see that there
is a lot of mitochondrial proteins
proteins associated with the proteasome
nuclear regulation that's something that
has been known in other fields looking
at situation that the epigenetics can be
controlled and modified by suchtelen
nation but in the heart we had the sub
proteome at the bottom called mile
filament and this is enriched again in
heart this is the contractile proteins
that are responsible for heart
contraction but the mile filament
proteins were also one of the sub
proteomes that were enriched and altered
with such elimination in heart failure
so contractile force is produced in the
heart and that what was that allows it
to contract and relax and pushed our
blood out into the body and up and up
top our pictures really of an isolated
cardiac myocyte and this was actually
done in a collaboration with David Kass
and Jonathan Kirk and they did this
beautiful set of assays to babe to
figure out in an isolated cardiac
myocyte whether or not we would change
the fourth production of the mile
filament proteins when those proteins
were such eliminated and that's what you
see on the left hand side so in what you
do is you take it I selimiye aside you
remove the membrane and all the soluble
proteins and you're really left with the
mile filament and as you add increasing
calcium concentration jul those proteins
will contract and you can measure them
and you have an increase of force when
those myocytes residual inated so when
we treat it with them pad we were able
to shift the calcium sensitivity and
that's actually very important in heart
failure there's two major parts have
happened one is you get a decreased
force and we have many mechanisms that
we know about in our field that does
decrease
but what's been missing is really the
ability to figure out a mechanism that
will change the calcium sensitivity and
that's the other part that happens with
heart failure you require more calcium
in order to induce any force at all and
so citral ination obviously changed
forth by the calcium responsiveness and
on the right hand side what you see is a
schematic of the mile filament proteins
you of the thick and thin filament the
thin filament being composed of actin
tropomyosin and the troponin and then
you have the thick filament which are
the myosins and also you have the emmons
edline proteins which help to
essentially align the mile filament
proteins and keep them in alignment and
what is color-coded is those proteins
which were situated so in black almost
all the proteins labeled while all those
proteins labeled and black are situated
protein in green are those that should
change with ischaemic heart failure and
then read those which were changed with
a dilated heart failure so both heart
failures were modified and there were
specific proteins within the mile
filament that were more modified
compared to control healthy hearts so
when we step back and thought wow this
is the first time anyone show and that
citral donation can happen in the heart
that can change contraction and practice
was a mechanism forth to understand how
we were changing calcium concentration
of calcium sensitivity and heart disease
but as I mentioned earlier what's
interesting is that citral donation can
also be auto antigenic so we came forth
with a kind of bigger hypothesis that in
the heart itself during heart failure
you will have situation happening
including two proteins like cardiac
troponin i which is already a
circulating biomarker that when you have
a heart attack you will release or
increase your release of cardiac
troponin into the bloodstream we monitor
it and if it's super elevated we know
that you're having a heart attack so we
thought well if this is happening in
heart failure which we know there is
continuous leakage of cardiac muscle
proteins into the blood and if it's
modified and if you have such a nation
perhaps if it's long enough for you have
severe in that heart failure perhaps you
are actually releasing the modified form
of troponin i and thus could be antigen
and it could drive actually an auto
antibody response so we have been
proposed
that with heart failure as you progress
and you're having more such Allah nation
of our proteins and if they get released
as a they will with heart failure you
could stimulate an auto antigen response
and another antibody response that would
then drive and make your progression
worse and perhaps the difference between
how individuals progress with the
disease is not just retracting
mechanistically within the cells but
also inducing an author antibody
response so we went after it at this
concept by taking heart tissue digesting
at sorry fractionating it extensively in
to about 500 fractions arraying them on
glass wells and so now what we've done
is we've taken hearts from normal as
well as from ischemic and dilated heart
failure fractionated them arrayed all of
those fractions which will contain
anywhere from one to two hundred
proteins and then started to screen
serum against these proteins and these
proteins remember we'll both be
unmodified as well as citral inated so
as we screen patients which are have RA
and patients which I've RA but have a
heart failure or have increased calcium
scores meaning that they're at the risk
of heart failure we were hoping to be
able to find some other antibodies being
induced in lead babe to they would bind
to the array and we'd be able to detect
them so that's what happened he has two
examples when we did this some of the
spots kept coming up as being potential
other antibodies or proteins that are on
auto antigenic so we analyzed by mass
spectrometry those specific spots and
cardiac proteins which were citroen died
were found in those fractions two of
them with myosin and troponin and so
what we did on the second one is we took
purified myosin human myosin and
purified human troponin we took them and
we sit chillin aid them and then spotted
either the unmodified or modified forms
of myosin and troponin and then ran the
same Sarah back over them and that's
what you see on the right hand side you
can see that especially in the bottom
with troponin that the red which is
troponin when its modified with such
relation has a large response so this is
the auto antibody response or Auto
antibodies in these
for individuals that have RA are binding
to the troponin that's modified but not
the unmodified form so in other words
this is some of the first indications
that modification bicycle nation of mile
filament proteins and we suppose other
cardiac proteins can be released into
the blood can cause an auto antibody
response and can we can pick that up
using these arrays using the citroen aid
form of these proteins as bait so now
that's the reason why we want to care
about Spanish determination and being
able to find drugs now that are able to
modify and modulate the pad enzymes are
a way of going forward again this was
brand new data that's coming out and
determination had never previously been
shown to occur in the heart so how can
we scale this and how would you go
forward to actually making the
biomarkers so to do that we have to be
able to do large numbers and so in the
pipeline of proteomics you go from
samples to being able to do sample prep
where we do this digestion so
essentially we do protein denaturation
reduction alkylation digestion using
either lycée for social nation or
trypsin for normal protein quant and
then we have to dissolve and get it onto
the mass spectrometer and then we need
to do data analysis either the targeted
mrm assays or things like dia which was
the example i just showed you with a
desalination and then of course we don't
have to understand and get knowledge
from that and moved to more clinical
assays so we needed scalability so over
the last few years we've been working
with Beckman culture and Sykes to
develop this pipeline really on the
automation that sample processing and
I'll talk about that and again when you
have increased sample processing you get
both an increase in time so you're able
to do it quicker but also you should be
able to improve the reproducibility and
the coefficient of variance should be
driven down and we hope driven down
towards that of the level that you would
get in a clinical chemistry lab so this
is Christy hunter shoes from sonic she
was our partner in this along with Mike
from beckman and essentially we used the
biomech npx sorts mxp system and we
erected to be able to do century protein
denaturation reduction alkylation
digestion
a 96-well plate and at the bottom what
you can see is really the CB along the
x-axis so we're going to try to get it
to be under twenty percent versus the
peptides that were monitoring in this
case this is all the peptides in the
sample that we would be monitoring which
was hundreds and you can see if we just
do manual prep which is if you're only
doing a few samples you can be very very
good with this you can have to see these
around ten to fifteen percent if you're
concentrating just on a few samples as
you start to increase the number of
samples across your CD is driven out so
when we talk about biomarker validation
we're doing hundreds of samples normally
even with the best people were hovering
with CBS over twenty percent maybe
between 20 and 25 percent and of course
some of that is from the LC response
itself and so with what we're trying to
do is have our automation system to be
equal to the very best manual
preparation and to keep our CVS low this
is a hat on two instruments is his chin
foo on our left side she is from Cedar
sinai she reads our high food put Center
and she was working with Christie hunter
to develop the system so we have to an
end XP system to biomech at Cedar sinai
as well as a psychic slabs and you can
see as we're comparing day to day the
reproducibility that the two instruments
are working very well and this is sample
preparation followed by mrm assays of
many peptides and again being able to
reach our CVS a while under twenty
percent so this is a protocol we've
reduced the protocol and essentially
what we do is we take plasma or serum we
add in beta gal that is our sample
processing control we put in as a
protein level and we're going to monitor
it a three peptides at the mrm a level
to know how well our sample is process
as well as our internal standards for
each of the peptides that we might be
monitoring we do protein denaturation
reduction Appalachian trypsin we
crunched and then we do online
defaulting on to the LCM SMS either 6500
cute reps or the 6600 triple toss and
essentially we now have the digestion
protocols down to two and a half hours
so you can do 96 samples in about four
hours with reproduce abilities
and what you get in a clinical chemistry
lab what this means however is that
you're able to do large numbers of
samples easier than we've ever been able
to do before this is to show you the
two-and-a-half-hour protocol and this is
tracking two different peptides you can
see you in fact we don't even need to
digest for two hours we can do it to
have much more either on the left-hand
side is beta gal Justin buffer and on
the right-hand side is what it looks
like if you're monitoring it in serum
and sound for plasma and we can monitor
both albumin as well as a beta del
peptide you can see that we can get
digestion in even shorter periods
probably between 30 minutes and
shortening down the total time required
to do sample processing down even more
so the online resulting turned out to be
very important add assaulting still
seems to be a challenge that we could go
over it seems to be still an issue and
so what we did on the 6500 was to
actually do a divert so we're able to
divert off the salt and then really have
the clean peptides go into the mass
spectrometer and this not only reduce
the time required to do the whole
processing but also was able to keep our
CPS very tight and this is an example of
looking at beta gallon human albumin
peptides over many runs and and able to
show you that we're able to get either
with online divert or online trapping
our CVS to be around hovering below or
around ten percent over many many many
samples so this is the total pipeline we
do automation now using the biomech in
about two and a half hours we're able to
add the m15 label peptides after the
sample processing we do online to
salting on to the 6500 and do data
analysis on the right hand side we're
looking at peak area or the CV of the
beta gal peptides that were spiked into
over 500 samples that were run in
triplicate on the 6500 and you can see
how tight the beta gal peptides that we
were monitoring again Veda gal being the
protein added before sample processing
so it's going to really monitor the CB
across the whole pipeline are coming in
around four percent or less than four
and over essentially what was a 5-day
run a continuous run on the 6502
quantify the set of mrm assays so it
looks like we're able to do large-scale
accurately for mr m and we are moving
this as sample processing to being able
to do it on dia again open up the
possibility of being able to do hundreds
of samples in discovery mode as well as
in targeted mrm assays of course a big
difference is that time of ms runs and
the number of proteins and peptides
you're measuring but we're still needing
to have good analysis of RA and
cardiovascular risk so in a
collaboration with Jonathan a diamond
Mike and Nick we went on several years
ago to try to find biomarkers that could
be very helpful to be able to predict if
you have RA if you're going to have
cardiovascular disease and so there was
a large number of outs I can't remember
60 or 70 antibodies pairs for Eliza that
were analyzed and a few examples are
listed there as well as we are lab with
responsible developing mrm assays and
then we analyzed them on several cohorts
and this is our mr MSA at the top you
can see all the peptides Gruer
monitoring and then still low this is
actually the setup of how we blocked all
the samples and all the QC that we ran
so he ran standard curves at the
beginning and end and we're going to be
again this is going to be about a five
day mass spectrometry run and we
essentially had cases and controls we
randomized those blocks and every group
of samples we would run a short QC run
which is essentially a 3-point standard
curve along of it so we're able to look
at both the beta gal across all of those
samples that we run which is what you
saw with CVS around four percent but we
also look at all the peptides which are
being monitored at all of these QC runs
across the five days and this is what
you can see here at the top you can see
the beta gal curves around the four days
the cds of the two peptides the red and
the green you can see they're very very
stable all under five percent and below
are now looking at one of the proteins
being monitored by three peptide by two
peptides and two transitions in each
prep
that's why there's two measurements per
peptide and you can see the three-point
concentration curve for each of the QC
over the five days and how reproducible
this whole pipeline is both at the
digestion level as well as the mass
spectrometry and this is looking out the
QC curve for three different peptides
again at the top being measured by two
peptides two transitions a peptide to
again is two peptides but the first
peptide is has three transitions from it
quantifying and peptide three has the
third protein has three peptides which
are being quantified at peptide 1 and 2
by 2 transitions and peptide 3 by 3
transitions and you can see how
beautiful the reproducibility is so what
we're doing now with the MPX were able
to run large scale both for mrm as well
as for dia discovery mode and in this
experiment essentially what we did is we
were run for samples per day and we did
the two-hour trypsin and we're
monitoring 70 proteins based on 990
peptides over 600 transitions and all
you need to take from that is that we
were able to replicate these incredibly
tight CVS across the whole protocol
again this is from the sample through
the whole sample processing the addition
of the internal standards running of the
samples through the mass spectrometry
really on these large mrm assays so
let's take a look at that data this is
looking again at three npx runs so three
different days as this is looking for
intraday variability and you can see how
beautiful for that many proteins and
that many transitions were able to get
under twenty percent CV so this opens up
the door of having discovery having the
same CV equality as you have for
clinical chemistry a phase so both for
discovery and for these targeted being
able to have the accuracy in proteomics
that are really as good as the clinical
chemistry labs so that's where we are
right now so what's next can we use as
technology and push it even further if
you can do 500 samples why can't we do a
thousand samples why can't we do 5000
samples why can't we do five hundred
thousand samples if you start to talk
about moving in that direction now you
can start to talk about
patient centric health screening at the
population level so this is kind of
going to where the future is and we hope
the future will be very quick so what we
can do now is you can take blood spots
so you can put your finger and put it on
filter paper and send it in and analyzed
by mass spectrometry lipids small
molecules and proteins obviously higher
abundant proteins in the blood we've
been working with a company that has a
volumetric micro sampling device called
Mitra this is a company called neoteric
and we've been working with them for a
while to be able to determine how we can
use this volumetric micro device to
sample blood from a finger prick and
they have two forms of ten microliters
in twenty microliters draw and this is
very precise and excuse me you can dry
them and then in theory ship them to us
and we can do mass spectrometry on them
and monitor proteins so we started this
project and no one had been had done
that yet on the meter device cotton
proteins out of the device so we're
going to develop that pipeline so why is
this important so right now there's a
lot of drive being able to use device
monitoring of patients a Fitbit being
able to use your phone to babe to
monitor heart rate and these devices can
go out to the population and you can
understand a lot about the physiology in
the pathophysiology know type by using
these devices but what's been missing
has been the quantitation at the
molecular level and so if you're able to
use these devices that you can prick
your finger accurately draw some whole
blood into that mail it to a research
lab and devour or to a pharmacy that was
my dream is to have this in the pharmacy
to be able to then quantify proteins
that can tell you really your health
status and then you can have very fast
feedback to find out and monitor whether
or not you're taking your drugs whether
or not your disease is progressing or
than not you're healthier if there's
some issue with your health if you can
do that if you're able to send these
devices out you can reach all
populations you can reach populations
who are not close to our health care
center you can reach populations that do
not want to come in to see a doctor but
and you can also monitor those patient
so they're coming out of a hospital or
on long-term care so there's a lot of
potential if we're able to collect blood
out in the community send them in and
get accuracy but of course what we're
talking about is large numbers and the
need to be very accurate and also having
the right biomarkers to be able to
monitor it so that you could actually
tell something at the molecular level so
the concept is with these new code major
devices is that is to be able to take
your blood and lips for some reason my
screen ok there we are it's a finger
prick your blood draw you to microliters
your air dry them and you send them to
us to do it so again what would need to
be able to do is we need to be able to
extract from these meet your device tips
to be able to do denaturation reduction
alkylation digestion clean up the
resulting and we have to have the right
mr msi to make sense of what we're
looking at and then today to quantify it
and then be able to get that information
back to our patients so these methods
are able to quantify any peptides so
these again can be peptides that are
specific to an isoform they can be
specific to post translational
modification so if you have a situation
out of an arginine residue and you want
to measure the concentration of that
particular citroen a peptide what you do
is you make an mr MSA to both the
central inated peptide as well as its
parent peptide that is unmodified so you
would be able to get a ratio of modified
to unmodified as well as if you want you
can have other peptides which are
unmodifiable from the same protein and
get a total protein quantitation so
that's the beauty of mass spectrometry
and something that you cannot do with
Eliza's what Eliza's what you can do is
you can only measure one epitope so if
you wanted to modify our measure
modified form you would have analyzed it
to the modified form and additional Iser
which you would have to run separately
for the unmodified in mr MSA is because
we can multiplex oh well we can have in
the same multiplex peptide
that represent the unmodified protein so
you get total protein concentration and
then for that very specific site that
you want to measure thats it related
site you can have a peptide that that is
to the unmodified peptide as well as to
the one that's modified so you can
measure the central innate peptide the
equivalent unmodified the scituate plus
these independent peptide so you could
have multiple measurements that are all
run at the same time in the same
multiplex you can do that for
phosphorylation you can do that for
which we've done for cardiac troponin i
we published a paper several years ago
where we tracked in a single mrm a say
over 12 phosphorylation sites as well as
the total protein concentration of
cardiac T&I based on a thirteenth
peptide and we're able to really get
accuracy of measurement of every single
phosphorylation site of that very key
protein as well as total protein
connotation and for the first time
measure independently each of the
phosphorylation sites and actually the
data that came out of that was quite a
unexpected and exciting for the field
that there was brand-new phosphorylation
sites no one knew about before and they
were the ones that were changing more in
heart failure than the classical sites
that people had been measuring and
focusing on so it really changed that
field from focusing on a subset of
phosphorylations to brand-new set which
we think are driving heart failure this
is a type using things you can do with
mrm assays and it's also to whether or
not you're doing in a clinical lab
whether or not you're doing it for
research or doing it like we're talking
about here on the major devices where
we're trying to do it on large scale you
can get the specificity of the disease
by toning in on those disease modified
forms and quantifying both the total
protein concentration as well as the
modified form itself in a single assay
which is essentially so exquisite so the
way that we needed to be able to move
from our traditional and nxp automation
work system to being able to do it on
the beach device took some work it was
done by a wonderful post doc in our lab
and every inventor broken and
essentially these are the changes that
we did from our normal to the major
device and the big difference is that we
had been working in plasma and now we
had to work at home
blood worked very well and here is an
example of the mrm multiplex that we
used on mitra and you can see the
peptides are representing different
proteins and this is a great example
that if we had a modified form for
example in beta gal and let's say this
was a modified form we could measure it
plus a peptide its unmodified form plus
peptides that were to two different
parts of the same protein and obtain
both the modified and unmodified
concentrations in a single multiplex
because these peptides behave very
differently and will be eluting at
different times and again at mrm we
exclude all the peptides from the mass
spectrometer except those that were very
interested in and so what we did here as
you can see we were looking at putting
the Meech devices in extracting the
proteins from the major device
denaturation reduction alkylation
digestion de salting online to the
triple-t onto the cute wrap and then
analyzing each of these proteins and
what I'm just showing you here is some
of the data for the April lipoproteins
a1e that we're measuring April eat with
three peptides april c 1 a plus C 3 and
CRP CRPS an interesting protein is a
protein that is very good for assessment
of inflammatory status of individuals so
to see reactive protein we're measuring
it from one protein you can see at the
very low abundant peptide its let me see
if I can get the the arrow to work you
can see it right here it's a very low
abundant but it's a very clean in the
mass spectrometry because we exclude all
the other peptides so we can assess it
and also sister Nancy and sis patency is
a protein that is measured and really as
a way or the new marker that's coming up
for being able to measure kidney
function instead of oxygen so since that
and ccrp you're going to be able to
measure kidney function CRP is going to
give you information status of course
April lipoproteins who's the surrogates
for your lipid panels and so already
we're able to just on these proteins
able to assess an individual based on
several of the key parameters for
wellness
and essentially when we did that if we
were able to do an NF six and then again
over three days you can see how tight
the coefficient of variants are for
these particular peptides and remember
what we want to be able to beat is 20
percent TV that is done in the clinical
chemistry labs I mean I must clarify
that in clinical chemistry lab many of
the assays are better than twenty
percent but that is really the cutoff we
need to be under twenty percent in order
to have the same quality assay so where
are we and what did we talk about well
what we talked about today is the
ability to get at mechanisms and
sometimes these are new and unexpected
mechanism such as the modification sigil
ination in heart value which had not
been known until just really recently in
the last two years and the fact that the
situation can impact contractility at
least it looks like it can based on
research studies and that means that we
could have a mechanism with being able
to maybe inhibit and block as a change
in calcium sensitivity and heart failure
which has been today not been possible
we don't have any specific pathways to
target to do that we were able to do
that by using a swath dia acquisition in
a new and interesting right by pre
building and pre enriching our library
so that we are able to have more
efficiently identify those peptides that
are modified we came up with the
hypothesis that this modification which
canon beyond to antigenic could in heart
failure being leaked out into the blood
and produce Auto antibodies and we have
preliminary data to show that this could
be the case especially if you have RA or
at risk we showed that being able to
have larger numbers by having very
efficient and robust sample processing
linked either to mr ms you started
disease or to discovery we're able to be
able to increase our numbers both for
discovery as well as for mr m assays and
this really when you have the pipeline
well you can have very good cv as well
under that of
clinical chemistry requirement and we
are able to monitor and assess proteins
over large long periods of time and keep
that very consistent and then the last
part to talk about this concept that
we're able to use mass spectrometry
because again in 10 microliters draw you
can't be running Eliza's you would only
be able to look at one or two proteins
but with mass spectrometry because we
can multiplex many peptides together we
can multiplex and monitor and quantify
many different proteins or many proteins
with their modified modified forms in
small amounts of samples and if we're
able to link that up with micro sampling
devices that can be done in the pharmacy
or at home or wherever you are that are
safe and effective to be sent into a lab
or we can monitor it we should be able
to able to effectively monitor at least
now how your kidney functions goin your
inflammation and your equivalent to your
lipid panel are we doing that yet no but
we're certainly on our on the way and
that is what the future holds as
promised to be able to do so I have an
amazing lab I'm very fortunate and in
red are those individuals that
contributed data and thoughts and
towards today's presentation as well as
we have wonderful collaborators both at
Hopkins and in rh own Adam and Mike as
well as we're very fortunate to work
with different industry partners to have
access to these different mechanisms
both the automation of the of the sample
processing for mass spectrometry and
also neoteric for working with us to be
able to work on the metra devices so
thank you so if you have questions I'd
be delighted to answer any and again I
wanted to thank you for spending some of
your day with me Thank You Jennifer for
bringing us that informative
presentation before we get started on
our question and answer session I do
want to remind our audience how to
submit their questions questions can be
submitted by typing them into the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to get
to as many of your questions as we can
today our first question attendee asks
do these methods
allow us to identify if all sites of
post translation modification or
modified in vivo what is the difference
in interpretation when modification is
done in vitro and then followed so what
a great question thank you for asking
that so first thing so traditionally
when we're doing shotgun for something
like phosphorylation we attempt to see
all the phosphorylation sites but you
don't the difference with the approach
that we're using where we pre make the
library where we on purpose try to
induce a hundred percent of that
modification and put that into the
library so if it's there we can see it
we increase our probability of seeing
and that's the advantage of this
approach of pre building a selective
library where we've really enriched it
hoping to be able to pull out those very
low abundant peptides that have that
mass occasion because we know what we're
looking for so if you know what you're
looking for you're more easily able to
see it then when you go hunting for it
allowed to approach so do we see them
all yes within limit of what our mass
spectrometry are able to detect so we
have a dynamic range of a mass
spectrometry it has you know from the
highest pundit peptide to the lowest
there's concentration so we are gradient
so if it's within that dynamic range we
can see it it's equivalent to analyze
that with Eliza we talked about the
lower limit of detection a low limit of
quantification we have the same thing in
mrm essays in the same thing in DIA and
discovery mode we have a lower limit of
detection in a lower limit of
quantification so as long as it's our
peptides are within that in our mass
spectrometry we are able to quantify and
really in the same conceptual way as you
do with an Eliza but of course if a
modification is below that detection
level we won't see it so it could be
there and we won't see it so in master
challenge ii just as it is with an Eliza
an absent to detect something does not
mean it's not there it just means below
our detection level but if we see it and
are able to quantify it we're pretty
sure it's there there are some caveats
both with Eliza's and with mrm where
that isn't always the case but because
in mass spectrometry we're also
measuring these transitions these
breakdowns
of the peptides we have additional
information that makes it so we can be
pretty confident that we're measuring
the correct peptide and because often
we're measuring more than one peptide we
can be pretty sure that we are measuring
multiple we're measuring multiple
measures of the same protein so it's
very good so the question is what's the
diff between in vivo and in vitro so
envy when we're doing it in vitro we're
trying to maximally modify it that's our
purpose we're trying to see them all
because in vivo of course that may or
may not be the case in what we're trying
to do is to quantitate each different
site and find out how they're very
varying within an individual and some
individuals you know like one may be
varying but slight to always happens and
so we're trying to find that site to
that's always happened like common
mechanism that common site we don't want
to know just different proteins modified
we want to know the actual site because
we find it's unlike with situation the
example I showed this when there was
actually different proteins that were
being set related often especially with
things like phosphorylation and
oxidation it is a different residue
within the same protein that's modified
and it's knowing that specific residue
that's important both for the diagnostic
as well as for the function and for the
therapeutic so thank you that I really
are wonderful question I see great
answer as well our next question does
discovery or targeted proteomics
approaches warrant Ottomans age
automation if so how big a lab or core
so that's also a great question so I
believe that we need to have very
accurate measures whether or not we're
measuring proteins for discovery or
measuring proteins for targeted mrm and
biomarkers biomarkers everyone infers
that we must have that we must equal
that quality that we expect from a
clinical chemistry Eliza so twenty
percent TV but I would say to you if
you're using automation there's no
reason that you can't have that with
discovery and especially in post
translational modification where small
changes can have drastic effect on
function for example the protein myosin
light-chain 20 is the protein that gets
phosphorylated when smooth muscle can
so if twenty percent of that protein is
phosphorylated you get full contraction
of smooth muscle so we need to as
proteomics people in discovery or in
targeted to be able to quantify twenty
percent of that protein being
transported as a specific residue now if
you're not having example processing
that allows you to measure with twenty
percent accuracy you can't you cannot
measure that change in that change in
myosin light-chain 20 is the most
important phosphorylation in smooth
muscle because essentially it's making
it contract so protein changes and posts
protein changes at the post
translational modification often is not
huge it's only twenty or thirty or forty
percent of your protein is going to be
modified and if that modification is
that a binding site that can change
completely how your cell who respond to
a signaling molecule so I would say that
you everyone whether or not you're doing
discovery or targeted need to be able to
do accurate measurement and certainly
automation a sample processing allows
you to do that along with standards but
equally if you start to automate also
then you can add more samples so instead
of doing ten samples you could do a
hundred samples if you do 100 samples
you could do a thousand samples and so I
always push back to people including my
own lab who does research and say why
are we doing 20 samples why are we doing
200 if it really is that much quicker to
be able to sample processing so you can
do 200 samples think of all the
perturbations and experimental
conditions you could do in a single
experiment and how much more
understanding we would have a biology
and if we were able to just increase by
a factor of 10 the number experiments
are able to do so I think small labs and
big lab should be moving in this
direction if it's series of small labs
and you could share an instrument as a
processing system but yeah I think small
and big law at labs I think in
proteomics really need to move to
automation of sample processing and with
inclusion of standards in order to track
the quality of your experiments and move
your numbers to larger to really help
proteomics do what we've been promising
it could do for a long time okay great
our next question
and from the identification of rogue
proteins have any Taylor medicines been
made what a wonderful question I wish
the answer to that would be yes but
excuse me sorry for bad cold but to date
no mainly because / dl makes an
identification of these model molecules
is only coming on at the scale it's
needed in the last few years but there
are biomarkers such as cardiac troponin
and I which the phosphorylation
modifications really drove and help me
find that particular assay that is now
the most common as a used worldwide for
really determining whether or not you're
having a heart attack and two new
markers that are going to be coming out
around a traumatic brain injury where we
know both the markers that are released
with traumatic brain injury these
proteins we can use for diagnosis but
they are also sakhalin aided and when
the solenoid we believe that they're
producing Auto antibodies in those
severe individuals who are injured so
these assays are coming on board we are
working with pharma to help them get
their drugs on target by monitoring the
phosphorylation status as they do
perturbations with different drug
targets to a specific pathway that they
want this is coming online so proteomics
is now really impacting it so
expectations is that we are helping to
refine already proteins and in a
collaboration again with David cash and
Jonathan Kirk that was published last
year on protein kinase G with a perfect
example of how proteomics was able to
help them define this kinase pathway
that there was two different pathways
depending on how you were stimulating
whether or not you had heart failure or
not to help those companies who are
producing inhibitors to target really
the right protein so that's also a great
example but it's not yet in the clinic
although clinical trials are being
planned okay great I believe that is all
the time that we have for questions do
you have any last comments or advice for
our audience just please I hope you
embody and an umber
proteomics and the scalability that many
of our labs not just our labs many labs
have been working hard over the years to
be able to really get to be reproducible
and robust to be able to do population
scale proteomics and we're at that point
now are there still lessons to be
learned of course but the exciting part
is that there's so much more that we can
do now both at the discovery at the mrm
level for really remarkable quantitation
in the clinical chemistry arena but also
in the population arena with these new
devices coming out so again thanks
everyone for spending part of your day
with me and I hope that you enjoyed it
Thank You Jennifer was wonderful
presentation lots of great questions
from our audience to that and if we were
not able to answer your question today
we'll definitely be following up with
you via email to get your questions
answered I'd also like to thank beckman
coulter life sciences our sponsor today
for making this educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
October 2016 you'll be receiving an
email from labyrinth alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to any colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
again for being with us you'll see you
next time goodbye